so here's how you want talking right
truth designing the Razr crest and you
know we do have some CG models that
we'll do but like John said it's a part
of a process you can see what the month
there's about yes that we thought about
earlier there's Landis 3d printing
pieces so we were able to 3d print but
those pieces are based on kit bashing
it's John Goodson who's built many many
models for Island over the years and
he's actually building the physical
razor crest old-school doing the LEDs
for the engines yeah and I think this is
John and his garage cooling the motion
control device because who can't do that
in their garage and there's what they
build in in their garages literally in
their garage studios the ILM guys built
like John's laughing because he knows
ridiculous and he's building this model
all the bell look there the 88 he ratted
I'm not gonna debate you and look at
look there he's like a lens crafter
making these pieces all him and Hal
Hickel Hal actually went and researched
all three of the old Star Wars films and
figured out all the flight paths and the
types of shots that they did where the
star fields would shift and move and we
sure and so here's here's the shooting
passes on the stage so here's how you
get the key and you'll see this is this
is done isn't that cool
it already feels like Luke's x-wing
right
and so they're they're letting us do
this and some reason because whenever
I've worked on something there was like
you can't shoot a model there's the key
and instead of doing it as a as an
optical printed we're using digital but
you can see the room there and and it
really reminds us of the old behind the
scenes footage it's it's just fun for us
they're all down in the basement
shooting that up at ILM and they're all
gathered around and evidently having a
great time it's really funny here come
here come the engine passes yeah you can
see that often there somehow they have
to do each for each lighting setup and
they comp it together and hold on what
there's a couple more these are the long
process it's fun for us we like it there
we go
it's so cool so anyway we're putting all
that together and we're having a really
good time this is really cool hi
everyone is Charlie they just showed off
a big preview of the Star Wars
Mandalorian live-action TV series that's
going to be premiering this November
with the launch of the Disney Plus
streaming service Sol explain what's
going on who the characters are they
revealed a whole bunch of details about
the series then showed off this promo
reel I'll be doing episode videos Easter
eggs for the series when it gets here be
sure to subscribe to get everything
obviously this premieres in November we
have episode 9 in December so there'll
be a lot of Star Wars stuff happening at
the end of the year but the funny thing
about the panel Pedro Pascal the main
character Oberyn Martell from Game of
Thrones
tonight his Game of Thrones night
because it's season 8 episode 1 in a
couple hours so just a whole lot of Game
of Thrones related stuff happening both
in the Star Wars universe and in real
life but as you saw during the preview
they're doing a lot of model work on the
series the ship is called the razor
crest that's his main ship is just a
repurposed old military surplus ship the
main character as you know Pedro Pascal
is just called the Mandalorian right now
they haven't given him a real name they
refer to him as mando Mandalorian so I
don't know they're gonna actually reveal
his real name during the course of the
TV series whereas one of those deals
like where Boba Fett never takes his
helmet off but obviously we know it's
Pedro Pascal so I assumed that this
character will take his helmet off every
once in a while they say it picks up
five years after Return of the Jedi
and part of the reason for putting it
during this period is because it was
such a chaotic time because there was
still vestiges of the empire causing all
kinds of chaos in the galaxy Pedro
Pascal says he spends most of his time
in the outer regions but I think that he
meant the Outer Rim territories for the
most part it's underworld characters so
if you were mad about the Star Wars
underworld game that almost got made a
long time ago it was just meant to be
the really seedy side of the Star Wars
universe that's what this series is
going to cover they did since there were
a lot of other big characters that he
would see pop up but they didn't reveal
a whole bunch of stuff they didn't get
too spoilery with it there was a
behind-the-scenes featurette they showed
off that they did not post online they
didn't allow anyone to record it but you
see Giancarlo Esposito Gus fring from
Breaking Bad flying a TIE fighter so
presumably he's an imperial character
they showed up a couple scenes starting
with Carl Weathers character grief
offering bounty - Pedro Pascal's
Mandalorian character he says what's
your highest bounty and grief response
not much about 5000 the Mandalorian gets
pissed and says that won't even cover
fuel these days grief concedes and says
well there is one job but it'll be
dangerous then you get a shot of the
Mandalorian walking through a market
with a bunch of aliens and droids you
see a salacious crumb looking alien
being roasted for food on a spit than
another one in a cage he knocks on a
door in an eyeball piece comes out just
like a Jabba's palace during Return of
the Jedi the door opens there's another
droid that looks exactly like one from
the original Death Star during a new
hope he enters another room with a whole
bunch of stormtroopers in it you see a
shot of Werner Herzog's character who
notes to him grief carga said that you
were coming there's a doctor that
wanders into the room the Mandalorian
almost shoots him but the stormtroopers
pull their guns out noting we'll have
you four to one
but the Mandalorian isn't worried
because he's a badass he says I like
those odds
they're gunslingers standoff ends and
Werner Herzog's character hands the
Mandalorian some cargo there's more
sizzle reel footage of him fighting gina
carano scare achter who's another bounty
hunter
then fighting some more stormtroopers
they even said that there was a scene
they needed a whole bunch of
stormtroopers for and they didn't have
enough on set so they actually called up
the 500 and first people to come be a
part of the series but they wouldn't let
them take any pictures or tell them what
they were filming for the two of their
characters on the panel were Gina Carano
and Carl Weathers characters so
he plays Cara dune she's just another
bounty hunter that used to be an ex
rebel shock trooper that's just having
trouble reintegrating into society
post-war Carl Weathers is playing a
character named grief Marga I believe
that's his name I haven't seen it
written down yet in a couple of the
people in the panel pronounced it
differently he's the head of the bounty
hunters guild that the Mandalorian
character in gina carano is Kara dune
character belonged to and obviously
there are a lot of other bounty hunter
characters that belong to it there was a
picture of ig-88 that jon favreau posted
a little while ago making it seem like
he was going to be a part of the series
maybe he'll be part of this bounty
hunter guild the way they describe the
story is that it picks up with grief
Marga Carl Weathers character hiring
Pedro Pascal's Mandalorian bounty on her
character to go after a product that's
quote-unquote very valuable and bring it
to someone else for a very very large
sum of money the rumor is is that that
very special cargo is actually a little
girl that he has to protect through the
course of the series so as you would
expect his in the vein of a samurai film
or a Clint Eastwood Western a la man
with no name Pedro Pascal even
specifically called out Clint Eastwood
yeah my characters got a lot of Clint
Eastwood in them so if you're a big fan
of those western films it's gonna be a
lot like that there are a lot of people
that are wondering now if they actually
just took Josh Trank's idea for a boba
fett Western and turned that into this
series but it sounds like Jon Favreau
came up with this separately because
he's the one that said he pitched it to
Lucasfilm it wasn't Lucasfilm going to
him with the idea the reason why Dave
Filoni is on the project is because he's
sort of like the resident Jedi Master
when it comes to TV series at Star Wars
so Lucasfilm paired him up which on
Favreau to produce the series they
actually worked together on Clone Wars
before because Jon Favreau voiced the
character Pre Vizsla who wielded the
dark saber for a long time they even
told the story about how George Lucas
had to create the dark saber because
they needed the Mandalorians to wield
the weapon that could stand up to a
lightsaber in the vibro blaze wouldn't
do it George Lucas is like no way the
lightsaber would cut right through one
of those we need to give you something
more powerful so he came back a couple
days later he's like I got something for
you I just created something called the
dark saber
[Music]
the two of them originally met on
Skywalker Ranch when Jon Favreau was
doing the sound mix for the very first
Iron Man film way back in 2007 before
the 2008 premiere in Dave baloney was
working on Clone Wars season 1 also at
the Skywalker Ranch separately so they
got to talking and they showed each
other their work and he was like hey I
got a new character we just came up with
it's a Mandalorian name Pre Vizsla do
you want to voice him so that's how jon
favreau wound up working on the Clone
Wars series Fabro even said that when he
was pitching the Mandalorian Series to
the Star Wars powers-that-be
he sent the scripts that he was writing
ahead of time to Dave Filoni to read
just to ask him what he thought about it
so if you're fan of Jon Favreau's
storytelling you're fan of Dave Fallone
ease work in the Star Wars universe it
just sounds like they have the best of
both worlds there they didn't say how
many episodes it's gonna be I'm assuming
somewhere between 8 and 10 episodes and
they didn't say how many seasons they
plan on going hopefully at least 5 but
they're spending so much money on it
that I think it's gonna look pretty
amazing and it'll just be a side of the
Star Wars universe that we haven't spent
a lot of time in and remember that there
aren't gonna be any Star Wars films for
a good long while after Star Wars
Episode nine the CEO of Disney confirmed
that there's an official hiatus on Star
Wars movies now I think that's only
gonna be for a couple years before they
announced plans because the game of
thrones producers are still developing
their Star Wars trilogy which is rumored
to be in the Old Republic era but we
don't know much about that Rian
Johnson's also still developing his
trilogy separately but neither one of
those will drop for probably the next
four to five years it's gonna be a long
time before we find out what those are
gonna be so for the next couple of years
the only brand new Star Wars live-action
content that we're getting is gonna be
from all these Disney Plus series that
are doing there's the Mandalorian series
which is premiering November 12th as of
right now there's gonna be a Star Wars
rogue one series that they'll do that
won't premiere till either next year or
the year after
then there's the rumored live-action
obi-wan Kenobi's series remember the
obi-wan movie that we heard about that
was in development it sounds like it's
just gonna be a TV series now which i
think is actually better you get way
more obi wan content
just a reminder though Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 1 is premiering tonight
my video for that will post after the
episode airs just like I do every year
it'll be the same schedule of
videos that I've done for previous
seasons so no worries while you wait for
everything click here for my last big
Game of Thrones episode one teaser and
click here to rewatch the Star Wars
Episode nine trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you